quelle mouche a piqué Thierry Frémaux le
délégué général du Festival de Cannes a
été filmé en train de menacer et même
bousculer un policier municipal devant
l'hôtel Carlton en fait Thierry Frémaux
l'accusé vivement de l'avoir frappé
non compris
je vous ai demandé le plus arrêter
[Musique]
apparemment Thierry Frémaux circulaient
en vélo électrique sur un trottoir un
endroit où il n'avait pas le droit refus
d'obtempérer et surtout une menace
le cogner parce qu'il est là il faut le
retenir et surtout lui dit je m'occupe
de paix de vous quoi
vous avez compris monsieur
[Musique]
vous m'avez tapé vous m'avez frappé vous
m'avez frapper bio avec frappé
c'est l'impunité l'impunité de de ces
gens là de ces mondains de Cannes mais
le code de la route c'est pour tout le
monde et surtout refus d'obtempérer et
il est hyper menaçant monsieur Frémaux
il veut jouer son influence alors que
tout le monde auto lui dit qu'il est en
tort mais non monsieur Frémaux n'est pas
en retard parce que Monsieur Frémont
c'est le Festival de Cannes et il sert
la paluche des stars américaines on s'en
fout c'est un justiciable comme un autre
et ce tout mon soutient et tout notre
soutien à ce qu'on à ce policier
municipal bien sûr on est au-dessus des
lois parfois pour certains on vous
demande de vous arrêter bah non je suis
Thierry Frémaux je ne m'arrête pas vous
n'êtes rien vous n'êtes policier vous
n'êtes rien monsieur bon bah d'accord ça
a une forme de condescendant mais bien
sûr un métier bien sûr qui est au lieu
d'être
une forme de et après on fait des films
forcément pour vendre le contraire on
peut vous dire que les vrais stars
n'étaient pas à Cannes elles étaient
dans l'Indre
saurait vous trouver les stars qui se
sont fondus dans les images de JT vu sur
TF1 par exemple le gars qui dort sur sa
caisse en pleine journée
alors c'est vrai que Charlotte comme on
dit c'est envoie un Savoie bien du du
pâté du bon pâté alors
[Rires]
sur ce plan de France 3 on adore le Move
de monsieur qui a dû faire le même
pendant tout le weekend
celui-là le rassemblement
cherche champi svp avec un petit emoji
champi il y a aussi une femme vêtue
d'une robe aux couleurs du drapeau de
l'Ukraine qui a fait éruption hier soir
sur le tapis rouge elle s'est aspergé de
faux sang regardez
[Musique]
sur ce plan de TF1 sera-tu trouvé le mec
qui n'a rien à faire à plat ventre dans
la terre
le plan est très court mais il est là
les vrais stars étaient aux équival
techno festival ça fait technival techno
festival c'est devenu technique
mystère c'est le maître du temps il va
permettre à tous de traverser les
époques quel est ce dîner qui commence
déjà avec les portes de l'enfer c'est
plutôt les portes du temps qui vont
s'ouvrir bon je comprends direct qui va
falloir un combat cet petit voyage je
pense que quand faut y aller faut y
aller je sais pas où est-ce que ça va
nous emmener ce truc là mais moi que ça
donne pas des hémorroïdes ça me va c'est
à l'histoire
de
Pluton
vous êtes venus plus souvent ici en tant
comédien qu'en tant que réalisateur et
pourtant votre ambition au départ
c'était de devenir metteur en scène j'ai
raté ma vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Emmanuel Macron a été reçu sur la place
centrale Dolan Bator puis au Palais du
Peuple siège du gouvernement et du
Parlement pour un entretien avec le chef
de l'État de Mongolie si je vous dis où
l'âne batteur
ah excellent
oui
excellent
mise en scène super
et les infos elles n'ont pas si je vous
dis Oulan-Bator
bon je l'aime bien
mais c'est pas quelqu'un que je suis
beaucoup mais moi je le valide vu le
petit geste rigolo mais un peu humiliant
du Canada sur la Corée du Nord du Sud
c'est rigolo mais c'est humiliant quand
on s'appelle Sarah Salman on gagne
combien par mois
on verra après on verra après c'est bon
je répondrai après c'est bon c'est bon
pourquoi vous bloquez sur une question
comme ça alors vous savez très bien vous
qui écoutez Jordan on verra cette
question après là j'ai pas envie de
répondre à ça tout à l'heure après
on est un pays qui est malheureusement
gangrené par l'assistana c'est aussi
pour ça qu'on trouve pas de gens pour
travailler là où c'est difficile c'est
sûr que quand ça n'est pas un job de
naturopathe en télétravail les jeunes
Français veulent pas le prendre ben il
serait temps que on supprime les
conditions qui permettent aux gens de
vivre sans travail
[Musique]
pécuniaire qui n'ont absolument aucun
lien de cause à l'idée avec un livre
mais vous savez maintenant je suis pas
vue là pour écosser des petits pois
c'est bon
vous vous me posez non mais parce que je
suis venue là pour parler de mon livre
alors là c'est fou c'est la première
fois que quelqu'un se barre comme ça